from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by draftkings we hit
the final week of pro football and we're
just getting ready for the national
championship in college football now
draftking sportsbook has an unbelievable
offer for you this week new customers
can bet five dollars on any football
team to win their game and if they do
you're gonna win 203 bets i've been
singing
this song to you since
football started this year and a lot of
you guys haven't gotten on board i'm
telling you this is the best
bookmaking operation in the world online
draftkings is tremendous so let's wind
down the season with a big win if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
you can still find your way to the
winning circle everyone can play huge
cash prizes with draftkings daily
fantasy football contests fantasies are
live and kicking it's hot right now
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at a million dollars in total
prizes with their first deposit
draftkings has given
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prizes
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey and i'm gonna
get you five dollars you're gonna win
200 on the nfl team college of pro if
they're victorious now
if you want the daily fantasy app you
got a preston joey also that's promo
code joey this week at draftking
sportsbook now you got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only minimum 5 deposit
and a dollar wager required
one per customer very important
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
call one eight hundred gamble but if not
head over to craft kings and let's win
some [__] guitars start tonight
with little monday night football the
joint is also brought to you by
zip recruiter listen 2022 is gonna be a
big year for a lot of businesses but
some industries are projected to grow
even more this year like home
improvement everybody's getting tired of
looking at that [__] rundown house if
you're in a business in one of these
industries you need to hire asap and
there's only one place to go
zip recruiter listen
whether you're looking for a job you're
looking for an employee
zip recruit is tremendous and right now
you could try zip recruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
joey i'm going to give you a free little
account you can easily review recommend
the candidates and invite top choices to
apply for your job which encourages them
to apply faster no wonder zip recruiter
is the number one rating hiring site in
the u.s based on g2 ratings zip
recruiter technology is so affected that
four out of five employees will post on
zip recruit and they'll get a qualified
candidate within the first day that
could be you now also try it everybody's
looking for great employees you guys not
immune to what's going on today right
now try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com
joey again
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire or get hired
let's light the candle baby
it's 20 22. let's do this [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's monday the 3rd
of january
it's a whole new [__] year with a
whole new ship
with a whole new set of old [__] rats
that's the way we're looking at it it
was a great little holiday i'm happy
that uh
we took the [__] week off because i
got covert done all the time
i finally got covered for christmas uh i
tested positive christmas eve it was
official christmas day
best thing that [__] happened to me
in a goddamn long time you know
everybody had been fighting not to get
this [__] everybody thought they were
immune to this [__] but
like i said we're all gonna get it
eventually
it's how prepared you are for it
i'm a fat [__] i'm out of shape i got a
fungi toenail i got sleep apnea i got a
bunch of [__]
so i had to be on top of my game
throughout this whole thing i knew rest
would be it and i got to be honest with
you
i know where i got it i got it at my
daughter's kickboxing place the lady i
was talking to
monday before christmas her husband had
it
and we were bullshitting about it she
said you know he took all the [__] uh
bells and whistles and he was doing okay
but i think i got it from her it
developed
uh
the 23rd pretty much i could feel it i
had a chunk of [__] diarrhea come out
of my ass chicken bones garlic cloves
everything that could come out came out
and i knew something was up i had body
aches but you know us guys we're working
out we're walking
going to jiu jitsu i'm an old man so i
get sore if i [__] whack off
so i didn't know what the [__] was wrong
with me yeah i whack off i get sore like
i throw a back muscle i haven't wiped
off in a while but just saying when you
get older [__] you gotta you pull the
muscle [__] uh you get the flu
whacking off you know
so you got to be careful you got to be
on top of things i'm really happy i
listened
i'm very happy i went and bought
backups on all those [__] vitamins
you know that was the first thing i did
when i felt better last week i went and
got some more [__] body my my my wife
get the okala whatever the [__] that is
the d the zinc
and does it help guys who the [__] knows
i don't know
i know i feel better i look better my
thinking has been great and i got to be
honest here i was [__]
you know i always thought when people
pulled up the test or when they got the
test in the email how you would react
like i was always thinking about that
how am i gonna react when i get it
when i got it man i swear to god when my
wife said i was positive
i had a little fear maybe
four percent believe it or not i had
four percent that i was gonna die like i
thought it just crossed my mind for a
[__] second
and then as the night
went in i can't believe how i felt
lighter
like i was like 20 pounds [__]
lighter when i went to get a water that
night and i was like wow
i feel this much [__] better
part of my whole dilemma
was the fear i had a covet and i'm big
enough to admit hey man
if you look at a lot of people today i
do your reading mental health
has been a [__] part if you don't got
covet
you got a little mental health issue
right now not everybody's gonna make it
out of this [__] live in the
words of
jim morrison this is uh
you know i've been here for the last
six weeks telling you [__] that
2022 is our year we're gonna make it
work and listen
we are gonna make it work and we're
prepared and we're ready to go my goals
are written i'm reading the art of war
you know it's back it's the first we go
back to the original thing and i've told
yous all but i feel like i let you down
because it is going to be a great year
for us we're still going to keep doing
what the [__] we need to do
it's our surroundings we don't know
where this is all going it's not [__]
good
we're going to keep pushing no matter
what you know like i always say it
doesn't matter who's president you got
to keep getting up in the morning call
me when the president says listen i'm
going to mail you a check a nice check
and you don't have to do nothing but fan
your [__] [__] all day that's the
president i walk i i vote 10 times for i
[__] get rid of my you know over the
break i try to do the right thing guys
and you guys have been on me for years
my friends have been on me for years
family members have been on me for years
like listen man you always talk about
the felonious exp experience but guess
what you're not in the felonious zone
anymore you've been out of that zone for
20 [__] years
why don't you go get your [__] record
whatever the [__] has sponged and all
that [__] well guys i was working on
that for about a week and a half and i
got to tell you something all these
attorneys that called me that were
friends of mine and were like oh we
could do that just making a call [__]
when i called the attorney he took the
case he took the situation he's like
i'll do it
but i'm not making any guarantees
because this is a [__] nightmare
you got to get everybody in colorado on
board
like everybody like the arresting
officers the d.a
the prosecutor well first of all the
prosecutor that prosecuted me has long
he [__] flew the coop
right after my trial he became an
environmentalist he went to work for the
[__] feds he went from prosecuting me
for kidnapping
to going to go after people for [__]
throwing a piece of paper out the window
wasn't that small but you know those
businesses that [__] throw syringes
in the ocean and [__]
those [__] so he went from
kidnapped for me he went from
prosecuting my cuban ass to kidnapping
to [__] whatever that let's just
start with that guy my attorney he's in
colorado springs i think he's a slip and
fall guy now he don't even do criminal
[__] law
the the two cops the one cop retired and
me and him okay we talk on facebook from
time to time he don't want me to he
don't want nobody to know but he's proud
of me and i'm proud of him we both you
know made amends to each other the other
[__] detective he's not gonna go for
it at all i know this [__] this
[__] still throws arrows at me
and [__]
he there's a comic in boulder who's a
cop like a part-time cop and i worked
him one weekend
at the comedy works and he was telling
me the [__] this cop was saying listen
he ain't lying
but that was a long time ago let it go
slick
just because you stayed as a [__]
punk-ass
foot soldier in bold and didn't do
nothing with your [__] life that's
not my [__] problem
i changed i changed for the better and
i'm happy about it but
you know what after thinking about it
i'm just going to leave the record there
i don't give a [__]
i did it it's done time to move the [__]
on
and go on to the next mind [__] and see
i don't forget about it seattle don't
ever want me up there
when i [__] got a guy to go down and
look for my records in seattle that
[__] called me back and he goes
listen
your records were so [__] buried in
that
stock room that it took me like a week
to get them like nobody gives a [__] but
they want me to go back to you know what
i'm gonna sit right here tight if we
need a passport i don't know we'll
[__] print it up ourselves i know
friends who get passports all the time
but now you ain't going nowhere they're
looking at that passport with a [__]
you know what i'm saying
they're deep in that [__] passport
now they're looking for vaccines and
[__] so i'm just gonna sit right here in
new jersey
i don't give a [__] you know but that's
what i was doing before i was trying to
do so many [__] things i want to get
an office i called 20 people i talked to
three realtors every office i looked at
i got one more hope that building an
office building down the corner did you
see that that's all i was talking about
yeah and i went there the other thing i
was like i'll call you like the [__]
10th of january i'll let you know we
have something in the back that's small
i said listen but i want to be outside i
don't want to be in an office office i
want to be outside like i want the
office we had like we could go outside
there's a little yard in the back we
could shoot [__] videos you know
listen i mean it doesn't look like we're
getting any guess for the next two
months
so i mean i'm not killing myself but
that was the whole thing it wasn't just
for the guest it was to shoot little
videos and do little things i have to do
here like this morning i had to kick my
daughter and my my wife out for [__]
two hours because you know we got [__]
to do with people to see i'm down here
yelling and screaming saying [__]
racial epithets and she's upstairs i
can't have it and that's why i was
thinking about like mike like
if we had an office we could do podcasts
that night i love that you know
a little watercolor suckers you got to
hydrate you know what i'm saying
god that's the most important thing of
this covert but i will tell you what i
did do
that was pretty [__] interesting you
know and i'll walk it for you guys i
don't give a [__]
i tested positive on a thursday
confirmed it on a friday
and then friday i just relaxed it was
christmas eve you know i didn't my wife
and my daughter moved upstairs i was in
the [__] basement with the door open
freezing to death i had chills i had
sweats
the first couple nights i [__] sweat
the first two night the second night
guys
i had to get up in the middle of night
take a shower
take all my clothes off
and change the [__] bed that's how
much sweat
i was sweating like the first two three
nights i was drenched and even last
night i had a little bit of [__]
sweat because i'm still sleeping with a
sweatshirt on with a hooded sweatshirt
i'm time to sweat it out but i'm gonna
tell you what really i caught out of
this covert
i was watching you know listen guys all
you have to do is write the first three
days all i could do is maybe write
i tried to play the guitar i got [__]
dizzy you know
i just drank ate checked my temperature
checked my oxygen levels i was the first
[__] three days you know
and then
you're home all day you know you can't
do anything i mean i opened up the
garage i went for walks i breathed i
mean this the second the first and
second day i had it
it was gorgeous out so the girls were
gone so i would open up the garage door
and put a [__] lawn chair out there
and get vitamin d with my blanket
because i knew vitamin d would help
[__] kill the coving i mean just
natural vitamin not drinking a gallon of
milk or [__] taking pills and [__] i
want [__] son you know so i went out
there both days and now i was out there
one day getting son the next day i was
out there for a few [__] hours
but at night that one night i think it
was uh christmas eve night
i was up the girls came back they went
to bed
i couldn't sleep
and uh
it was like two or three days of
watching tv i was on my second day of
watching tv
and you guys know i can't deal with
[__] tv all day you know i could deal
with like half time of a game
a period here a quarter here you know
and then i walk around and i do all this
[__] i mean i i watched a ton of movies
during the break i watched uh
[__] cobra kai i watched
i watched i started watching the wire
again because i had watched everything
but
the christmas
eve something happened that night that
really it made my christmas eve it was
[__] great
i was sitting there and i noticed there
was nothing on tv so i started reading
the book bob lingard sent me this led
zeppelin book
trust me i'm on like eight [__] books
on led zeppelin i want to kill this year
i love led's apple i love everything
about them but so i was just looking at
the line of notes and she like that i
noticed the longest yard was on
longest yard is on every [__] day if
you let it you know
i'll be honest with you guys i watched
it when it came out in 2004 i wat i mean
i went to two premieres i went to like a
screening
and then i watched it again with some
friends and after that i was like i'm
not watching this anymore when it comes
on tv
i always look at the scene it's on i
giggle and i just scroll by it that's it
i can't sit there and watch that movie
go that's me i i can't that's [__]
embarrassing guys so
and i let it go you know when people get
those movies like i know a thousand
people that get those movies
and they won't go for another movie they
just hold on to that movie for years
they wear the gear from it they wear the
t-shirts from it
and that's their big breakout thing you
know when i did the longest shot 2005
when the year ended i put all that [__]
away i'm finding [__] you know what i
found last week in this closet i found
something i haven't seen
exactly in 16 years
i found you like when you sit in a
hollywood chair they have your name
on a thing behind it and they have like
the longest shot or whatever movie
you're in
i found my chair thing that they told me
not to take they're like don't take that
you're not allowed to take it i was like
[__] you
i took that [__] to go i had not
seen that thing since we shot the
[__] movie
and when i was cleaning out the closet
the other day we had me and mike talked
about cleaning out that closet
for three months that closet when i was
a kid there was a tv show about some
cartoon guy every time he went for the
closet the closet fell on top of him and
he would have to unbury himself and [__]
and then the rest of the afternoon he
would put the [__] back in the closet
then the next day he would open up the
claws and the [__] would fall down
guys i had so much [__] in that [__]
closet i had boxes in there
that i had not opened up from the move
like there was still four boxes from the
[__] move
that i took out of there one day this is
how boring covert is because covert is
boring as [__]
you're not gonna trust me you get i
can't watch tv all day
so i came back here i would do the
[__] closet in sections and then i
was finding the [__] that was mine i was
bringing it to every room that it
belonged to once and for all you like
when you pick something out of a box and
you're like i'll put that upstairs later
and two months later the [__] uh the
one all-in-one [__] uh light or
whatever the [__] you bought it's still
sitting there i didn't want that's
what's been happening here since the
first day we took [__] out of boxes put
on a table and said oh in a week i'll
move that up it never got moved
so what i did was i put my [__]
iphone on and i tracked my steps i must
have walked 3000 miles that day putting
everything exactly where it [__]
belonged i threw out so much [__] that
was in there i know my bro everybody's
like give me give it to me there was
nothing in there nobody wanted
it was like open [__] but but uh ball
waps
from manscaped it was a thousand things
that were like individuals like [__]
that had broken
t-shirts that were old i found the
t-shirt from my cocaine days i didn't
even look at the armpits
i just threw it the [__] away you know i
was like i don't need to look at this
[__] but that's done
i cleaned out the garage i had a desk
that was [__]
filled with junk
i cleaned that [__] out i mean i
did a lot during the coven except go out
or [__] be able to do [__] so when
you're stuck at home you might as well
look at all those [__] projects i
worked out very lightly i just waited
till like uh
the fifth day and then like the one day
i just walked around
the front you know when you have covered
this covered i don't know which one oh
if it's omicron i don't know
i didn't look at the [__] swab guys i
just know
that you know i had a little shortness
of breath
there were moments when my
oxygen would drop to 93 that's as low as
it went
my pulse is great you know i have one of
those little [__] pulses i put them
on every day this summer i would wake up
to a pulse of 38.
that's how bad my pulse was this summer
and i would jack it up work on it work
on it work on it so
anyway
but back to the [__] longest yard
before i [__] confuse you
[__] or what was in the closet
the closet's done the closet looks like
a [__] million bucks i'm happy i got
one more thing i want to do in there
mercy drew all those pictures you know
pre-k k
first grade second grade
well not really second grade first grade
i got [__]
folders of pictures so what i'm going to
do is just put them into a one big
folder and maybe save them for i don't
know how i'm going to put them away
because if you put them away in a box
they're going to get [__] wrinkled
but uh when i was watching the longest
yard that christmas eve like i was like
i don't want to watch this [__]
i went i was doing something i was
getting weed ready to do a bong or
something like that the next thing i
[__] know i'm watching these scenes
and i was watching like i was watching
the scene but not really
i was remembering what we were doing
that day like that's what i was saying
like my mind wouldn't focus on just the
movie
every time a different scene switch i
was like i wasn't in that scene i wasn't
there that morning because i didn't want
to [__] put the costume on
towards the end i was just a [__]
rogue on that movie but the thing i'm
getting to is
while i was watching that movie i
realized who i was when i shot that
movie i'm not the person i was today
i was [__] handicapped at that point
guys
i really was handicapped mentally
physically and psychologically with that
[__] cocaine the question i had for
myself after watching i didn't watch the
whole movie i got depressing after a
while because i was it all kept going
back to i can't believe
i was in that bad shape
when i shot this movie not not because i
was 418 pounds
but the amount of drugs i was doing
up to shooting this
while i auditioned you know who i was at
that time when i shot this movie
there's no way
i don't know how i booked that movie
i don't know how the [__] i got into his
office i have no idea
it saddens me at one point of it but the
other part [__] makes me really happy
because it'll show you that even when
you're on your worst
you could still be at your [__] you
could still be doing good things i mean
listen
when you look at that guy in that movie
you're looking at a guy at that point in
my life that did not give a [__]
about anything except
succeeding
except getting ahead that's all i cared
about
in my world it was like i was getting
ahead by shooting a movie
but i was taking two steps back by
snorting coke are you with me
but i didn't see that then
i didn't see that i had focused so much
on comedy i'd focus so much on my comedy
career there's no joke
that i didn't give a [__] about my
health
i mean i sacrificed my health
for the [__] that movie like not for
that particular movie
but you think about it the shape i was
in at that time i mean let's be honest i
couldn't even climb up my steps
i was i was having a hard time
going up and down three flights of
[__] steps guys
if the elevator would break
i would not leave the house
it was built to me psychologically that
i couldn't [__] leave the house like
i just couldn't do it
i wouldn't even bother to walk down
there you know when i watch that movie i
watch i think about me going into the y
when that movie finished
and signing up for a free consultation
and the guy going listen man after like
10 minutes i'm going
i can't help you
you're too [__] fat and you're too
[__] out of shape i thought i was
dead but you know what i didn't care
about how fat i was
i didn't give a [__] about how coked up
i was i wasn't cooked up when i was
shooting the movie i don't want you to
understand that not at all there was no
way i would do coke and try to do a
[__] scene that's not gonna happen in
my world i'm talking about what i was
living through at that time
five nights a [__] week you know
getting high
not caring about myself eating like a
[__] savage from you know 10 eggs for
breakfast mcdonald breakfast is it was
four or five sodas before lunch time you
know i just wasn't right
so the question looms on me how did i
get that movie
what pushed me [__] forward
to get that [__] movie till this day
i'll never know
but i guess it was just the
the want
i wanted it
[__] badly man i didn't give a [__]
all i wanted in those days i wasn't
looking
for [__]
i was thank god i had a girlfriend at
the time because i wasn't in the mood
for [__]
i wasn't in the mood for getting my dick
sucked at that 2004
all i gave a [__] was making my point
[__] hurt that that's it
that was that was the end all [__] be
all i just wanted
to do something with my life you know
when i shot when i finished shooting
that movie i was 44 years old
i had nothing that movie
just you know
took me sucked me the [__] in for
everything i had and i went there and i
came through like a [__] fat cat i'm
very very proud of myself for that
there's people that are sober
and can't do what i did in that [__]
movie and i'm not trying to [__] uh
you know push smoke up my ass but it's
the [__] truth
you know we had catherine narducci on
here a couple months ago and and she
told me before the premiere
of the many sayings she goes watch it
enjoy it and take it in
and for the first time since that movie
had come out in 2005
it was the first time i watched it
embraced it
sucked it in and said what the [__] was
i doing there
and nursing guys for a lot of when that
movie came out you have no idea what i
was going through i was getting [__]
hate mail every day
i was getting hate not in the mail like
the mailman would deliver you know there
was no instagram there was none of that
[__] but i was getting tortured on
[__] like uh myspace i think and uh
whatever the [__] was out my own hotmail
like people were [__] sending me [__]
like you're not italian why are you in
that movie what's it got to do with it
[__] uh what's his name played in the
godfather he wasn't italian i mean how
can you play big tony comics a bunch of
[__] comics who remain nameless you
know that was nothing at the time and
there's still nobodies
they got together they really are
they're they're really nobodies they got
like a circle together like joey's not
italian you know and they wrote a letter
i had them sandler
somebody wrote a letter out in the sand
i was a coke fiend you know people were
telling me to my face i wouldn't have
got that movie if it wasn't for joe
rogan how many times
have you seen adam sandler on the joe
rogan experience
okay so shut the [__] up you know that
was a long time ago those people who
said that [__] are probably long gone
they're probably nick the victim into
victims somewhere they're [__]
who knows what the [__] they're doing
but it was a [__] nightmare going in
there every day because i didn't know
who was gonna come out of the woodwork
with another [__] comment
i don't go joey you know
but all that aside man
when i [__] finished that movie like
i didn't finish it i just turned it off
and kept reading but it it [__] up my
mind a lot it [__] with my mind that
i didn't give a [__] about anything else
i was just worried about comedy
and now
i don't even know who that person is
like i look at that person 16 years
later i was trying to figure out who
that [__] guy was you know all i saw
was a fat guy with a lot of heart and i
was [__] scared of [__] in that movie
i was scared of dying i was scared of
getting fired from that movie
i was scared of getting outed and
when i watched the movie the scenes i
was in i mean i watched the scene i was
laughing my ass off guys
it was the movie scene we were in the
movies and
i was controlling the vcr and all that
[__]
i went back to what was going on that
day there was two two scenes that stuck
out in my head
the vcr scene and the movie thing we're
watching the opposing team and i gotta
tell you what what scene killed me in
that when we were eating the [__]
turkey and the cranberry leg and all
that [__] the cranberry juice was like a
mock it was like a real cut in scene let
me tell you something that scene
took like 12 [__] hours
and it was a friday and they brought in
a bunch of fried chicken
they brought they were turkey whatever
the [__] chicken whatever the [__] they
had
they stocked it up
now to top it off goldberg was there
that day
and he was doing like that it just so
happened that that scene
[__] uh was shot on the same day that
a bunch of blind kids were coming on the
set like
guys i can't even
i can't even write this out for you i
can't even say these things to you i
think it was maury povich
is good friends with goldberg
so he cut a deal with goldberg it was a
friday
that the kids were going to come in like
all these blind kids
jerry lewis kids you know they were i
don't know what type of kids they were
just not
in good shape my heart goes out to them
i'm not trying to make jokes here i'm
just telling you these were [__] up
kids
i don't know he was bringing like 40 of
them or 50 of these [__]
and that day
was the same day like three dudes said
dog it's friday don't forget to bring a
quarter ounce of weed
you
so i was like holy [__] i got to pick up
a pound of weed
and go down there you know sorry
dog it was like clear it was like
yesterday i still remember waking up i
still remember you know i had the money
at the house for the quarter pounds i
had to get i had to get like three
quarter pounds so i said [__] it let me
just get a half hour
a half pound and so i called the
armenian he brought he had this
tremendous weed at the time there was no
weed stores there was none of this [__]
i was getting weed from this [__]
dealer that was a beat
but there was uh you know the coke
dealer had some weed from time to time
that was pretty good but my main weed at
the time was the armenian
and i'll never forget
these guys at the they were rich they
gave me [__] they were like how much
work i don't know what i told them it
was like 700 i would tell them 900. even
though i was making money they're rich i
got to bang them out what the [__] i've
been banging out poor people [__] 30
000 years when you see all these i never
understood like restaurants like when a
hollywood guy comes in
like they give him a free meal [__] him
all these
companies send you free [__] like tons
of free [__] i always think about like
the little guy
like what the [__] like when i used to
get two albums from that company i would
always give an arm away like i always
that's what i do
i call dean delray jim i mean i haven't
got none since mike but i would give it
to mike lee i'm one of those [__] but
these people would give you free [__]
constantly and i'm like what the [__]
but you paid you make the poor people
[__] pay i i never understood that
[__]
what are we talking about i don't
[__] know hear this
i feel bad for mike because i always try
to hook mike up with the latest gadgets
the latest reefer i always do i'm very
loyal to my friends but
i got some stars of death in last week
from my company we're putting out a star
as a dead chain
he told me when he came to lunch he goes
listen you consider him putting
a [__] edible line i go yeah i'm
working something with abx for the
capsules
but
you know i like to [__] uh do
something else he goes how about a star
of debt
so he sent me two kinds of stars of debt
he sent me
the blue ones are made with like delta
nine or something like hemp based
products and cbn and something else
there's a sleepy time one and the red
ones are 100 they're both 100 milligrams
i'm sorry i tried to get them to 200 but
legislature's cutting us down i'm sure
they'll be
i'm sure there'll be some 200 on the
markets they told me that they're
getting ready to shoot a 500 they want
to put together a 500 milligram one so
what we're doing with laughing gas and
2022 is this
cocoa is still there the 35
laughing gas is still there that's
always going to remain
what we're going underneath is we're
going with four wheats
one's gonna be like 36
38 and one's gonna be [__] you're
going to the insane asylum after this
[__]
72 [__] percent
we got two edibles we're getting
licenses for vegas we're getting
licenses for
colorado and new york and new jersey new
jersey's open new york's not gonna be
ready for two years
so it looks like i'm going into the weed
[__] business guys and that's
the business i want to go into like i
told my wife who said 30 years of
smoking dope gets you nowhere you know
what i'm saying i proved that [__] wrong
[__] so all you [__]
that your sisters your brothers and your
uncles told you to put that [__] down
it's never gonna get you nowhere they
were wrong
[__] them i told you every no good deed
comes back unfucking turned whatever the
expression is so 40 years of smoking pot
paid off okay
so i'm very proud of that you know i
don't know how to grow weed
and i don't know genetics i don't know
that [__] but i know how to smoke weed
and i know how to review weed and i know
how to tell you [__] this is
the weeds you need to go look at this
[__] we came up with this week
this is a different this is nothing from
ice cream shop
this is a different company a dear
friend of mine started growing weed
about 20 years ago he grew the first 29
strawberry cough i remember bringing it
to the philadelphia [__] helium the
guys were on stage and i would blow pot
at them
from the side and they're like trying to
crack jokes and they're looking at the
smoke coming at him and rogan was like
get that [__] away from me 29
i'm talking into the butt like it's a
microphone that's when you know take a
look at this [__]
[__] beautiful woof
oof is [__] mooches and i let it dry
for mike when i got it was a little wet
you'd smoke it you go this way don't get
you hot now you and this is a sativa how
many times you guys see me smoke sativa
never
i'm smoking because his sativas are so
[__] strong
you get like a [__] chill to it
whatever
but my point with the longest yard was
man was that i'm
i'm proud i did it
i can't believe i did it i can't [__]
believe i mean i can't believe that's
that was the thing that shocked me the
most the uh night guys
that i could not believe i was in that
movie i never dreamt of that i still
remember seeing the original
i still remember going to the screening
of it
after the movie was done in florida for
the super bowl
and how pissed off i was because i
wanted
to be like the original i didn't want to
see adam sticking his finger in his
mouth and putting in the guy's ear i
didn't appreciate none of that [__] but
i appreciated me being on that set i
couldn't till this day guys i don't know
what gave me the belief to even send
that audition tape in i mean i told you
guys
thousands of [__] times and i was not
kidding you
that when i stepped foot in los angeles
in 97 i sat down i didn't know much
about goals and all that [__] then
but i did and i wrote down goals and one
of the goals was to try to be an extra
in a movie or a tv show that was my goal
that was my goal usually i put like a
goal like and then three reasons how i'm
going to get to that thing i would just
want to be an extra for some reason i
never thought
i would ever get on a set and i never
really thought
that somebody was stupid enough
to let me on a [__] set i didn't know
the politics of it so i didn't know
anything
and once i got mad tv and [__] i
remember leave those places going
oh well
wait till they look at the [__]
background i guess nobody looks at
background reports i guess nobody gives
a [__] if you stab somebody in the eye
with a pencil i mean nobody ever said
anything to me i put it as far away
from my mind as could be for starters
when i was doing all that [__] i lied to
you guys when i tell you that i think
about i don't think about anything to do
with that [__] felony
that's as far away from my mind this can
[__] be better yet felonies
plural that's as far away from my mind
as can be like i don't
let that take me down at all that's why
i didn't give a [__]
about the sponging you thing you can't
get rid of who you've been
you can never [__]
you know
what if somebody does want to hire me in
two years
and they do do a background check
and they see that it's been sponged
like they'll go what the [__] joey you
told us but then you would sponge it
listen man you can't change
what you were back then
but you could change who you are today
and that's what i do every [__] day i
try to be a little better some days it
works
some days it doesn't you know but
hanging in there and keep throwing
spaghetti on the walls the only way
you're gonna get forward you know it's
2022 man and i uh
i really wanted this to be a different
year first of all
i think i'm done with all the external
[__]
like we made the tapering go away i'm
feeling a lot better i've lost some
weight like i didn't think i did
accomplish anything last year like i was
walking around here in october feeling
like [__]
what's happening you bad [__]
you know
the joint is sponsored by better help
online therapy now we've spoken about
that out on this show before and this
month we're discussing some of the
stigmas around mental health first off
it's not for crazy people it doesn't
mean something is wrong with you talking
to a therapist is a positive way to
process life i've made some [__]
great
you know
results with
betterhelp.com dana has opened up my
mind to different things
i know i could see now when i'm getting
anxiety i address it and it's just like
you're going to the gym with dentists we
should be caring for our mental health
as much as this physical health so what
i'm doing is this better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist you don't have to
see anybody if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you're not going to find the
therapist right now they're all booked
up you can start communicating with your
therapist on better health in less than
48 hours give it a try and see why over
two million people have used better help
online therapy
this sponsor is podcast by bedau and
you'll get 10 off your first month
10 percent off your first month when you
go to betterhelp.com
d-i-a-z
is the code that's betterhelp.com
diaz and check out betterhelp's new
podcast getting better stories of mental
health
near meghan trainor opens up about
motherhood or how the nba hall of famer
chris bosh
tames anxiety find getting better on
apple spotify and everywhere else where
you find podcasts but listen if you need
someone to talk to better help is going
to help you the way they help me press
in codias
and get 10
off your first month
and then i started thinking about my
work with eric on the book guys
i'm more excited
for this book to get finished than i was
for any specialized shot
anything i want to do with comedy i got
to be honest with you when i started
writing this book last january
i wasn't all there in this book and i
think that
we're gonna have to go back to the
beginning and add some spots i think i
missed some spots i wasn't really
at a good place mentally
i think i started getting into this book
you know because it was the same story
if you tell the same [__] story every
day i was trying to write this book for
[__] 10 years
i wrote this book already
five times with five different people
they would always bail they would have
something else i would have something
else i would [__] look at it for a
month
and finally i got somebody
who was what i mean we spoke i told her
she had to stay on for the whole book
the whole thing erica is doing a
phenomenal [__] job but i tell you
who else is doing a good job i am i am
by [__] sticking with it
you know i've had to peel back the
layers this is harder for me this book
because right now i'm not writing about
my mother dying
i'm not writing about the easy stuff me
going to jail i'm writing about getting
cleaned
getting married right now us looking to
move right now i'm in the chapter when
we just moved to the valley
and i'm looking at all this [__] between
that
and the longest yard guys i didn't
remember half this [__]
this is why i was talking to him about
the longest shot this morning we always
talk about the longest shot but not from
this angle
i was watching that movie last week or
whenever the [__] two weeks ago
christmas eve
and i got to be honest with you i was
put there mentally
and i was like what the [__] i wasn't
even here mentally when i was on the
[__] set i was too busy doing coke
and you know
i wasn't in good spirits when i did that
movie there was a part of me that was
you know i was focused for the movie i
was focused to be on that set obviously
you could tell from me being in that
[__] thing i was in that goddamn
movie but i wasn't
my mind wasn't [__] there when i look
at it now i can't believe i did what i
did and when i'm writing these chapters
in this book
i can't believe i did all that [__] and
that i had the
like i was on to something
after 2005 after i saw that movie i had
a huge rock bottom i had rock bottom i
can't believe how bothered my head and i
kept [__] pushing
i kept pushing you guys didn't know
nobody knew when i was doing at the end
of that movie what i went through not i
think joe knew you know i was having a
hard run at it with the drugs
you know i was having a hard run at it
at the house i was trying to
hide it from my wife i was trying to
keep you know you can never live your
life right when you're hiding something
from your best friend once i realized
she was my best friend it made my life
so much [__] easier i didn't tell her
i quit coke until a year after i quit
coke that's who we're at right now at
the book we're about me telling her and
her being in shock first time i told my
wife
my wife knew i was getting high she just
didn't know the extent of it
and she didn't know the things i was
doing the first time i told her the
truth she cried like anybody else would
if i told you guys the truth you know
i've told you the truth here through
jokes and whatever i've never told you
the hard dirty
facts of being on the floor and getting
up and crying after you're doing coke
and i wouldn't let myself look in the
mirror and like it was just the
creepiest [__] thing i went through
so when i shake shake that [__] when i
shook that [__] thing
i didn't know what i had shaking i had
shaken like a [__] curse
it was a goddamn curse and watching that
movie the other day let me know that
i don't know where the [__] i was at and
i'm sure i'm not the only i'm sure that
there's musicians i've read where
there's musicians
that the band has broken up
they've been out of the band for four or
five years i read a thing about [__]
jimmy page
that you know when he was doing uh that
band with
rogers
remember that band
keep me on tonight i'm radioactive
i'm radioactive when when bottom first
broke up when bottom first died
i think led zeppelin tried to do a a
couple things but then like by 84 the
guy from bad company
and jimmy page formed the band i can't
remember the name of it right now wasn't
bad
they tore it a little bit you know they
took a little bit
and then like
i don't know i just read this maybe five
years ago
that it took him like six years to
unwind from led zeppelin
you know with the heroine because he was
on heroin throughout the whole led
zeppelin thing he was on heroin on their
last [__] that well i didn't do a
last tour
but before they recorded into the
outdoor
he was a bad heroin [__] addict i
mean if you don't believe me look at led
zeppelin live from uh that festival they
do rather damn or i mean uh
you know
when the skinny did it with the stones
a bunch of [__] fan everybody has
done it it's tremendous to show
what's the name of the
the firm
i think during the firm
i remember reading well not during the
during the firms when he came to the
conclusion of it
i read this about four or five years ago
that he had not
like he didn't remember all the songs on
his albums i don't remember [__]
can you believe that like jimmy page
didn't remember songs from physical
graffiti
and you got to look at that and go wow
how the [__] don't you remember songs
from physical graffiti you're jimmy page
well guess what
now i know why he didn't remember the
songs
from [__] i mean you just black out
on life
there's chunks of my life that are
[__] missing
there's weeks of my life
that are missing that i can't even put
together guys i don't remember last
christmas
out of my anxiety
you know some of it i blame on the
anxiety some of it i blame on the drugs
some of it i blame on old age
but some of it i gotta be honest with
you guys i blame on just blacking out on
my own
like i didn't want to be present and
i've done that
you know thousands of times you know
i mean
mostly you don't want to be present when
somebody's [__] in the ass and you
didn't [__] sign up for this you know
but
[Music]
my in my world you know
i always wanted to be alive for
everything like i want to be a party
ship and guys
i got to be honest you're the [__]
drugs the edibles
those edibles took their [__] toll
with me i don't want none of you
[__] to go oh
joy was eating 2 000. listen
if you don't think while i was eating
those 2 000 milligrams i knew
you know look at these guys i went to
vietnam they're over there shooting
vietnamese people having a great [__]
time they came back and got agent orange
you know what do you think
they didn't know while they were
shooting these [__] rice paddy
[__] in their holes that there
was going to be you know any of you guys
if you don't think like that you're
doing [__] now pills coke
it's gonna affect you later listen you
smoke a pot you smoke a joint let me
kick you in there one time you're not
gonna [__] you're not gonna remember
[__] all right you're not really gonna
[__] remember [__]
yeah it's the equivalent of that i mean
you don't remember [__]
i
the reason what saved me
through all those [__] years was i
don't drink booze
that's the only thing that saved me yeah
i blacked out on some cocaine binges you
know sunk in some chick swat falling
asleep i had a thousand of those things
and then they refreshed your memory the
next day but
you know drug use is a [__]
it's always gonna come back to you and i
don't give a [__] if you think it oh
well edibles aren't going to do nothing
to me if you don't think
those 2 000 milligrams for [__] five
years
didn't affect me
then [__] it did affect me it did
affect me and yeah we're having a good
time here we crack jokes and [__] but it
affected me but i knew that going in
you don't think the first night after i
ate 20 capsules i'm like
this is not going to be good you know
there was a point with those [__] old
stars i was blowing gelatin farts
i don't know if you've ever blown a
[__] gelatin thought
did this cut i mean
you don't think i'm gonna have to have
stomach surgery in the future
you don't think there's gonna be a
problem
i do
i'm expecting it
nobody [__] needs
28 listen they should have put lee and
me in the [__] hall of fame what's
that
the the record yeah we should have been
in guinness and i'll tell you i would
love for one of you guys to watch we had
a star counter
a guy made a program for us a guy had
jiu jitsu on roberto crane's sweetheart
of a guy that we would shoot the podcast
and then we were supposed to
have
the thing that like uh like what you do
for us with uh
whatever the [__] the zoom
like that platform you make in front
yeah we had one for the podcast and it
was supposed to have like a timer
how many stars we ate and a goal for how
many stars like every [__] podcast we
were supposed to have like this podcast
we're eating 20 stars we don't know how
we're gonna get there if the guest eats
three
i eat 17 you know [__] like that
that was supposed to be up there we get
so high before the podcast
all those years we never said it
we never said it because we were so
[__] high we're like okay who gives a
[__]
we're already there who's gonna set this
[__] thing but if you look at some of
those old ones i think they had it up
with the the uh star of death counter
i mean even this guy's even though do
you see me i'm reaching for straws here
and i'm usually i can remember anything
from you know
my childhood i remember [__] stories
i remember the whole [__] thing
there's a kid i called the other night
on christmas
couple days after christmas i was
here with my family and for some reason
i started thinking about his father and
i just picked up the phone that night
like hey man
i was thinking about your father he was
a lot tougher than us when we were 58
and 60. and he's like what do you mean i
was telling him all this [__] about his
father we got to fight at the track one
time he's like i never heard these
stories what were you my father doing
i'm like dog you know me dawg i'm from
the back of beyond i would take these
dads and
[__] take them on a ride and [__] i
never my [__] i dated this girl in 84
and he offered me a job
and i had to take it because like you
know what do you do you know your
girlfriend's father offers you a job it
wasn't full-time okay i was working in
the city part-time i was rolling people
i was doing 20 different [__]
criminal activities then but i was
bartending i was legitimately bartending
and this guy offered me a job and i'm
like how the [__] i was one of those
guys like
somebody offered you a job you took
especially from dating their daughter
and he came to me he's like i'd like for
you to help me with this job it's just
two three nights a week i'll basically
pay you 50 bucks all i had to do i had
to do two missions on this job i had to
put hassle on the on the bathtub and
then [__]
go get him beers and open the beers for
him because he would have to wear those
yellow mom gloves to wash dishes and he
couldn't open up the beers you know how
many times i'd have to open up the bees
you'd pay me 50 bucks
for two hours just to open up the beers
but it was a
it was a bathroom resurfacing business
this guy got out he was brilliant guys
this guy showed me a lot about life his
name was john
and
i hooked up with him and one day like
she didn't tell me her dad had gone to
jail he had to tell me he goes you know
i went to jail i'm like no
tell me about it and he told me about
the whole [__] he was in there for
bookmaking it was just a year he was on
work release
but because he was part of the prison
one day they took him to like a job fair
in new jersey and they had this thing
called burma saram
and i can't believe i still remember it
and what it was was
uh a coding for the bathtub they still
do it today today it's huge now he sold
that company and made
millions
you know what he paid for that company
thirty thousand dollars he had to borrow
from his sister-in-law
and you had an automatic [__] deal
with sears so sears
was guaranteed to call you with eight to
ten jobs a month
at 500 job 500 a month he worked for
public service
but he would get home at night i'd meet
him at like 5 30 and we'd go do a job
and we'd get back like at 8 8 30 i would
get him stoned
i would do all the shitty i don't know
how many times he would call me next
thing go don't say nothing to my
daughter
but i couldn't feel my feet on the way
home what was that [__] you smoked with
me i was making them smoke chalk one
time this [__]
fell asleep in the tub
that he was doing
i got him so [__] up the tub was dry
and he goes i'm tacking dry yet why
don't you go sit in the car i'm gonna do
some stuff back here i came back 20
minutes later to see what he was doing
he was in the [__] tub
with the curtain on him and [__] would
hide him so the people who owned the
[__]
house couldn't [__] take a look at
him that's the adventures i used to have
with this [__] but i used to get
him high i used to take him to the track
i used to oh there was always a by the
way after we finished the job
like i would make him give me a ride
somewhere like never the city or harlem
or none but i'd make him give me the
rights like local stints and pick up a
gram of coke with him and sit in the car
with him he didn't know i have a grandma
coke but i was dating his wife
but he knew i'm not his wife his
daughter
but he knew about the reefer and all the
other nonsense that was doing so
[__] life man it's [__] great i'm
happy it's 20 22.
i'm happy i did this [__] podcast
today
i needed you [__] more than you
needed me today trust me i've been
sitting in the house
taking medication [__] testing myself
putting swabs in my [__] nose you
know i've been putting that how many
[__] covet tests have we taken so far
since this [__] has happened i don't
even have [__] stuff left in that
part of my nose like it's not here it's
up here you got to do it i don't even
have anything left i do that [__] i did
last night i gotta do it again today
and hopefully i'll do the pcr on tuesday
today monday i got a [__] physical
i'm taking care of all that [__]
it's gonna be a great [__] year man
but i gotta tell you something about
last week and i'll let you go
so sunday comes along i'm feeling okay
you know listen saturday came along
christmas day
i'm feeling okay
i was taking my vitamins i was doing
everything they told me to do
i hadn't called joe rogan yet i was
talking to jimmy florentine he goes what
are you going to do i'm going to sit
here
and take what i have to take and
hopefully one day i'll call a doctor
he's like you haven't called rogan and
told me and i go nut
he goes call him up man maybe
dawg everybody calls rogan when they get
covered you know what i'm saying and
rogan's got to [__]
give him advice i don't want to be that
guy
but finally jimmy was like call him up
i'm telling you he'll [__] tell you
what to do like all right i called him
up he this [__] was cooking for
his family
he called me while he was on the grill
he's like joey merry christmas what's
happening my grandmother's here not his
grandma's mom everybody was there his
wife's family the kids their friends
[__] it he's over there cooking like a
dog can i tell you something
i got covet he stopped
he just stopped i talked about on my
patreon podcast that
he really blew me away on christmas
night you know
we talked for like five minutes he asked
me where i got it what my symptoms were
he goes dawg somebody will call you in
10 minutes
i was like joe
don't even rush it you know i'm good i
don't feel anything yet
within 10 minutes this chick called me
tremendous mercy tremendous
her name was mercy i was like what my
daughter's name is mercy we started
talking
she asked me a few [__] questions
tremendous
because i'll call you tomorrow we'll try
to get this done tomorrow listen
it's not going to happen on the 26th you
know it's not gonna i know this already
going in
because you never know let's give it a
try so she goes i'll try again in the
morning she sent me some paperwork to
fill out i filled it out she called me
in the morning we spoke for 10 minutes
she goes okay
what local cbs do you want me to send
this to
i'm like what this doesn't come in the
mail she's like no
this is law 100 legit i'm going to send
it through your uh
through your uh
cvs late your doctor knows what i'm
saying i was like oh [__] tremendous
she sent me like a albuterol
spray
she sent me pills for congestion they
sent me
pills for a cough they sent me
steroids from my chest
you know for your lungs so you don't get
anything
these different people get cold with
this whatever variant is running around
i don't know
this [__] us government variant that
blaming everything on africa africa
hasn't bothered anybody in years they're
over there trying to kill [__] trying
to save elephants their husks and [__]
they're not bothering nobody i mean
that's what i told joe i think i got the
africans like no
first of all that's false information
two guys from england went to africa and
they got over vaccinated i was like
[__] rogan's got this down to a
science holy [__] he's captain vaccine
you know and sure enough she called
uh
sunday afternoon said the medications go
pick him up my wife went to pick him up
we came back i went on the medication
i thought that was it she called back
she goes listen uh
going to bring you an iv tomorrow we're
trying to get either monoclonal
antibodies whatever i know i'm saying it
wrong i'm you know i don't know about
this
and monday i woke up and she goes
somebody'll call you by 10
10 o'clock somebody called she goes i'll
be there at 12
i i was like listen i'll set you up i
cleaned out all this [__] lysol did
opened up all the windows
she walks and she's like when you test i
go saturday shoes
you're probably not even contagious
anymore
she's cause i've been working with this
since day one i'm like what she goes
trust me leave your mask on if you feel
better but i don't want you to think i'm
gonna die here i go all right she came
in had the [__] bleeker the whole
[__] thing man she was great
so now it came time for d-day you guys
know what i'm getting at the needle
okay
so again i was feeling okay i'd have a
temperature i just put my [__] arm
out
and she was like okay we're gonna put an
iv and then then i'm gonna shoot stuff
in for you while the iv is going in you
know i'll do an additional
b12 or whatever the [__] you need you
know
dog she tried to put that [__]
my wife was like dusting
like she was trying to open the window
and she had something stuck i remember
looking at my wife and going what the
[__] is my wife doing and all of a
sudden she pulled up the thing and when
i go out my wife looked at me and she
goes her [__] face just went
because i had just [__] lost
everything in my face she saw it and i
saw i saw that she saw that i lost
everything i had in my face so i looked
at her and i'm like i'm gonna go down
so i [__] start going down i'm like
okay
i'm like oh my god this isn't that bad
of a faint
i didn't faint i just was like a little
butts
and all of a sudden i'm like
thank god we got that over she goes i
missed the vein
we gotta do it again i'm like god damn
it
this happened with my [__] surgery
too my nose surgery was [__] terrible
so now they had to put in my [__]
hand
and she went to put in my hand again
i saw spots you know the whole thing
and
it didn't take
and i'm like that's because i didn't do
no [__] push-ups get that get these
heroin veins out i got some good [__]
veins guys and i've never done a heroin
i said give me five minutes i got on the
floor and started doing some push-ups
and [__] started throwing bruce lee
kicks in the air and i gave her the arm
the left arm now she she was all done
with the right arm i'm like god damn it
i got like two tries
left on
but i was feeling so [__] shitty i
mean i was done guys i was ready to pass
out
and she goes listen man
if uh you don't want to do what i
understand a lot of people have a hard
time with this you know i go yeah
i don't think it's gonna work
i've had this underlying
anxiety for [__] two years and it's
starting to come out again my heart was
beating
then i just started thinking and i go
what the [__] is wrong with me joey
you're 58 years old
you're not gonna let this lady stick a
needle in your arm and go listen let's
try the left arm
first pop after the push-ups
she goes it took
took about 40 minutes for the bag to
[__] drain i was fine
tip top magoo and she said i'll come
back tomorrow with the
monoclonal [__] antibodies whatever
the [__] they are
i knew what to expect tuesday i braced
myself to faint my wife wasn't here she
went to spiderman that morning with
mercy they could only go at 10 in the
morning i'm like god damn it
i'm gonna have to face this needle alone
oh by the way
a friend of mine fanny one of my best
buddies in the world gave me an ice bag
when i got into surgery you could shoot
this thing you could stab it with a
knife nothing
she gave me a gray ice bag let me tell
high my anxiety was that day my wife
took the bag when they were shooting my
arms and she put it behind my neck
and i couldn't feel it
no she also put a nice block on my chest
unlike when the ufc fighters come in for
[__] in between rounds and they put a
big bag of ice on that chest she put a
big chunk on my chest and i just sat
there and after the bag was all done i
go it's starting to get cold in here she
goes joey
you've had that bag on here for the last
55 minutes my anxiety and my body warmth
was so high
that i could not feel this atomic bag on
my neck and i could not feel this atomic
little there was a nice back on my chest
that's how high my [__] anxiety was
tuesday she came back
guys first needle it went right in i
didn't feel anything my wife wasn't here
i had the ice ready i had the other ice
ready i had this ice thing that i was
gonna put on my head and [__]
the monoclonal takes eight 21 minutes
for the antibodies treatment and then
she did another iv you know glucosamine
and
b12 and all that [__] she put a little
inflammation reducer in there a little
pain medication for my headache
and that was it it was nothing guys so
if you're scared of this or this whole
process it's a [__] piece of cake
tip
top [__] magoo
and for new years i had the best new
years in the world guys
i know you guys i know you guys had a
horrible new year's
new year's eve i sat here and i'm like
[__]
i used to have some fun on new year's
like i called a bunch of my buddies in
the afternoon i'm like hey we're getting
ready for tonight i'll pick you up with
an 8-ball and then like that was a long
time ago like holy [__]
new year's to me now means i'm going to
eat something good and go to bed late
early
in the [__] 20 years before that holy
[__]
we would buy ounces of coke and
quaaludes and i wouldn't wake up to the
fourth
it was horrible but this new year's eve
i had a nice day listen to what i did
i knew that cobra kai was coming on new
year's eve right so i go [__] i go mercy
what we'll do new year's eve is stay up
till midnight and watch kobe kai my wife
my daughter my wife looked at me all
weird like you're really gonna stay up
with this girl like oh [__] yeah
come new year's eve she asked me at
breakfast dad we staying up tonight i
looked at my wife's like you guys could
do whatever you want like alright let's
stay up tonight
we came down we watched uh something at
11 and then at 12
we were watching some [__] my wife was
watching it also i think we were
watching cobra kai because we didn't
have to wait till midnight cobra kai
came out that afternoon
so we're watching a couple episodes was
it that good this year
it was all right
they said a couple more [__] they used
some gender [__]
so my daughter
they did a lot of kissing a lot of
hugging
my daughter was look at me every time
they kiss like dad what the [__] i want
to see these people beat themselves up i
go that's not happening with this
it was a weird anyway it doesn't [__]
matter what i think of the show my
friends are the executive producers it
was a great show and i'm very proud of
them to do it
uh so midnight came
and my wife goes listen i left the
apple cider whatever the [__] they were
drinking whatever you drink with the
kids sparkling
sparking cider sparkling water whatever
the [__] it is
i left it at my friend's house we're not
going to have any spar sparkling go
don't worry about it
mercy goes that's no problem mercy came
down with like a bag of candy right
like you know
licorice and all this [__] she goes for
midnight i brought down a big hershey's
bar she brought down a nice big
hershey's bar and she goes we'll split
it up three ways
my wife goes i don't know if i'll eat it
because i'm gonna go to bed at midnight
it's the rest is up to you two guys
i made my wife take a piece i got honey
you gotta eat it she brought it for all
three of us you go upstairs you hang out
dawg
i ate
a piece my wife ate a piece
my daughter ate a piece
i didn't know anything about anything
listen it was like somebody gave her a
line of [__] coke better yet
it's like somebody gave my daughter a
[__] eight ball holy [__]
i've been around her for a long time and
i've seen it act up on sugar
but i never saw how this hopped up
this little girl was doing [__] what
do you call those things
the other ones
cartwheels
at ten to one she was doing [__]
she was doing that
uh exorcist [__] the the [__] remember
when [__] linda blair walked down the
stairs she was doing that
back and forth and forth all night long
on this chocolate i was trying to get
worried i'm like what the [__] she doing
you know the little kitten i had two
cats one of them died so the other one
cries all day
every time she cried mercy would go over
and do a dance for her whatever and then
they started fighting like they had the
tournament and you should see my
daughter throwing cakes flying sidekicks
i had never seen anything like that how
sugar affects the kid i know you have to
holy [__] i was freaking the [__] out
but i gotta tell you something
her and i sat there
until three in the morning
we giggled
we laughed at stupid stuff
she even went upstairs and said dad i
brought your hershey's no she goes dad i
brought you a peanut butter cup i look
over she's eating one through she knows
what the [__] she's doing she needed
just to do one last bump before she went
to bed
oh my god she started coming down at
like two
and i saw her just go
it was insane what sugar does to kids it
makes you [__] think man
but you know what that's the
we kicked it up a notch that night uh
we've always been pretty close you know
me and my daughter but
she's getting older i could see she got
older the other day broke my heart she's
not gonna be my little girl in a few
years you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna have to peel her up some
[__] arab fingers and [__] but i'm
prepared i got guns i got rocks i'm
gonna be throwing rocks like those
people in israel i don't give a [__]
jack
but uh it was a great [__] new year's
eve and it was that simple you know you
look at new year's eve for all these
[__] crazy things you're gonna do
and that night me and my daughter just
stayed home
watched the rest of [__] cobra guy
and we turned it off she was like i
don't wanna watch this [__] no more we
turned it off like episode 8 and we
watched the honeymooners marathon we
watched two episodes of the honeymooners
and then i knew dives drives normal
mobiles was on so i said [__] it
let's watch that and that was the end of
that that was our [__] new year's
she fell asleep downstairs
and uh i fell asleep on the chair to
about six
and then i woke her up and we both went
up at like 6 30 and that was my [__]
new year's eve guys and it was
uh was phenomenal i'm excited about 2022
i'm excited for you [__] you're
excited off for 2022.
we've been sitting in a [__] bush for
two years
so now is our time to sling some [__]
dick we've been worse than charlie in
the bush we didn't have to sit in a bush
we've been sleeping in the [__] bush
living in the bush there's nothing to do
with the bush now it's time to get the
[__] out and sling dick it's 20 22. like
i said to you guys do your goals get
ready it's going to be a phenomenal year
you're going to have the best year of
your life but
remember what i told you i don't know
what the outside has planned for us
and
who gives a [__] i don't give a [__]
what they got planned whatever they got
planned we're going to conquer it too uh
they took rogan's [__] video down
from youtube with that doctor
take a look at that video if you get a
chance if you could find it on uh
on spotify
he had the guy that invented the [__]
vaccine
yeah they took that video down
interesting stuff to learn
and uh it's time you [__] picked the
side [__] it's going down i love
you [__] with all my heart it's
monday january the 3rd
it's as good as we could [__] be
today i love you [__]
have a great week and we'll be back
wednesday tip top magoo
january 5th let all [__] hang out
i love you [__] thank you for
the support stay black have a great day
all right i want to thank you guys
i have no idea what i was saying today
but you guys will figure it out you've
been figuring me out for [__] 10
years the joint is brought to you by
better help online therapy listen
we've talked about better help on shows
before and this month we're describing
some of this crazy stigmas around mental
health first off it's not for crazy
people i mean i'm a little crazy it
doesn't mean something's wrong with you
there was something wrong with me and
talking to a therapist was a positive
way to process it
listen i'd love better help i got
therapy this morning with dana
and it's like going to the gym with a
dentist you're just caring for your
mental health as much as your physical
health i never thought about my mental
health but i was slipping but better
help changed all that that customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and live chats
if you don't want to see nobody that's
fine too you could just talk into a wall
i don't care it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with a therapist
in under 48 hours some years needed even
quicker give it a try and see why two
million people have used better help
online therapy this podcast is sponsored
by better help and you get 10 percent
off your first month at
dot com betterhelp.com diaz and check
out better help's new podcast
getting better
stories of mental health
here megan trainer open up about
motherhood or how nba hall of famer
chris bosh tames anxiety you can find
getting better on apple spotify
everywhere else you can get podcasts but
listen
go to betterhelp.com press and code joey
and get your life started again the
joint is also brought to you by
zip recruiter listen 2022 is going to be
a big year for a lot of businesses you
better get ready to hire some people
because everybody's getting tired of
looking and sitting there if you own
your own business
in one of these industries you probably
need to hire asap restaurant
construction home improvement and
there's only one place to go
zip recruiter and now you can try zip
recruiter for free what are you talking
about joey go to ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y you can easily review your
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job no
wonder zip recruit is number one
it's the number one hiring site in the
us based on g2 ratings listen guys it's
getting rough out there everybody is
looking for help you want to stand out
go to zip recruiter down
right now i'm gonna give it to you for
free with the exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y
that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire remember use code joey
to really get to them you understand me
now also
it's a great week this week okay it's
opening week everybody's [__] gone
away draftkings is even better now
than it was six weeks ago listen we've
hit the final week of pro football and
college football now we're headed into
the pro football
playoffs and national championship you
want to be there and you want to be
ready
and you want to have money to go new
customers better finn
on any football team
to win their game if they do you win
2000 free bets
so that's one dino season with a big win
if sports book isn't available to you in
your state i'm gonna take care of you
with draftkings daily fantasy
huge cash prizes
and they're giving away up to a million
dollars in total prizes
with their first deposit
whether you like draftkings daily
fantasy or the sports book i'm going to
make you money on both of them and i'm
going to give you a deal you can't
refuse draftkings has given all new
customers a free shot of millions of
dollars in total price in their first
deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey j o e y or bet
five dollars on any football team
college or pro and win two allows and
free bets if they're victorious
that's promo code joey
j-o-e-y at draftking sportsbook app the
best i had a great time with draftkings
over the holiday hope you guys can have
a great time with them also now you got
to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
new customers apply minimum final
deposit
and a one dollar wager one per customer
restrictions do apply now hey see
draftking sportsbook
for details now if you got a gammon bomb
call 1-800 gambler if not let's get this
[__] party started and put a bet in
tonight jack
i want to thank draftkings
i want to thank betterhelp and i want to
thank zip recruiter but most importantly
i want to thank you guys for having my
back
2022 is our year [__] i love you
stay black and have a great day we'll be
back wednesday morning tip top magoo
[Music]
so
you